hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and
welcome back to my channel so as a
productivity slash
lifestyle slash career youtuber or
whatever i
am who often talks about navigating life
and how to deal with it
i get why you might expect me to sit
here and tell you
that i have life all figured out and
that you should listen to me
because i know what i'm doing and always
have
you might even think that i have things
figured out because that's just what you
assume
about other people about youtubers and
quote unquote successful people
i get why you might think that but
that's not me
more importantly it's just not true in
fact
now more than ever i have no idea what
i'm doing
before we continue i wanted to say a
quick thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring today's video
i'm actually so excited that betterhelp
is sponsoring this very video because
part of the story is about therapy and
mental health and i think it's safe to
say that i wouldn't be who i
am today in overcoming anxiety episodes
and panic attacks and stuff without the
help of a trained professional
to help me understand my mind betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
and you can start communicating within
48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's actually professional counseling
done securely online
there's a really broad range of
expertise in betterhelp's 15
000 plus counselor network which may not
be locally available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide and you can log into your
account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly video or
phone sessions
and they're committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
it's actually more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
healthier and happier life today
so make sure to go to betterhelp.com
myuco that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional they're actually giving a
special offer for all of my subscribers
so you can get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
myuco
last year i left a career in tech to
pursue becoming a content creator and
youtuber full-time
it's been going really well but it's
also felt really
like foreign to me in a way that i have
like
trouble putting into words so as you can
probably guess
i've been spending a lot of time
thinking about this because
introspection is my hobby you see in my
old career whenever i would interview
for a job as a software engineer
they would sometimes ask me something
like where do you see yourself in five
years
and back then that was easy for me to
answer the tech world has kind of like
an established standard job path
and things often followed the same
patterns so i basically had three
options to choose from one was to
continue being a software engineer
the second was to become a manager and
the third was to become like a tech lead
or an architect of some sort
and they were perfectly legitimate
careers but i just remembered like not
being particularly excited by any of
them
the best way that i could describe it is
that they were just kind of vanilla
they weren't bad necessarily like
vanilla is a perfectly valid and good
flavor of ice cream obviously
it was just really standard like kind of
uninspiring to me
but their vanilla nests didn't register
to me as something that really
mattered in my decision they were just
the choices that i was given
like everybody else around me
subconsciously i was probably yearning
for something like
rocky road or hot fudge or something
just like something different
but at that point i hadn't even realized
that those things had existed
i thought that for me the vanillas were
all i had to choose between
honestly ever since i declared my major
in computer science
my freshman year of college up until
like
last year it felt like i was walking
down a well-worn path
i was surrounded by people just like me
all walking the same direction
all people would talk about was how
there were like a million jobs in our
industry
and how things were always growing and
deviating from that path that we were
all
walking on was seen as like kind of a
risky and
unconventional decision so there were
like these preset steps on that path
that
everybody would follow like get an
internship find a job as a junior
software engineer
put three years of work in move up to
seeing your engineer
and so on and i think it's only natural
that like the earlier you are
in your career the more that you're
gonna follow trails like that
when you're just getting started and
you're learning as you go and you're
like trying to grow in your career
it just makes sense to take others leads
on those things
and so it made sense to me at the time i
always thought that you needed to have
like a goal
or like a destination for your path in
life
like if you didn't even know where you
were gonna end up then it wasn't even
worth it to start
so i defined my own life and career
goals based on what others had told me
to do
and based on what others had done before
me it felt like it was the right thing
for me to do
because it was the right thing for them
of course it wasn't easy
to do all those things like it was hard
work but it was also just like
kind of expected if that makes sense
anyone who wanted to stay in tech
long term would benefit from following
these steps that's why being a content
creator has felt
weird in a lot of ways to me youtube and
creative work
is just different there aren't
interviews or like starter jobs to like
get a handle on things
i guess there are technically like
co-workers but
they're often just pictures on a
computer screen and you're still
alone a lot of the time especially when
you're starting out
finding success in tech definitely
requires some luck
especially when you're finding your
first job but the path after that just
tends to be a lot more predictable
when it comes to content creation
success always comes and goes
completely by chance or even
accidentally
you never really know when or why
opportunities come
it feels like the universe just randomly
decides to throw them at you for factors
you will never
understand and you just kind of have to
be ready at all times
so the idea of like random type success
isn't super new to me but i was
surprised just
how much unpredictability and ambiguity
there is in youtube
because there's like no road map or
rules or anything
it's like the wild west like it just
makes no sense sometimes
what i'm trying to say is none of this
was like according to plan or was part
of any plan that i had
and that was all in stark stark contrast
to my software engineering career don't
get me wrong
it was really exciting but it was also a
little
loose and erratic like the rhythms were
just different
there were fewer conventions to follow
and all of a sudden
i just realized i was so unprepared to
be a content creator
i had no idea how difficult creative
work is
i barely took any creative classes in
college
i just never even thought to quote
unquote work on creativity
or being creative because everything i
had done
was to get a degree and career in stem
but all of a sudden
i needed to learn how to adapt to
creative work like learning how to edit
set up cameras and lighting equipment
and design thumbnails
over time i started to feel more
confident in my initial creative skills
and i started having fun with it i saw
the impact that i could make
online i started to dream about the
possibility of
making videos full time and leaving my
job in tech
and eventually i knew in my heart that
this is what i really wanted to do
but coming from a job where i had things
to hold on to for safety
the thought of doing so was really scary
like in my old jobs we used to have
managers and supervisors that helped us
along our paths and resources like
leveling guides that
literally outline expectations for
skills and responsibilities at
different career stages step by step
they don't have that sort of thing in
content creation
no youtuber has ever consulted a pdf
about
what to expect when they hit 500 000
subscribers or whatever
so even though i was finding a lot of
fulfillment in my work in youtube
i just kept feeling this like really
powerful feeling
that even if i gave this career jump my
all
nothing was guaranteed like there was no
floor
or safety net beneath me and the future
was suddenly
so murky like would i still be making
youtube videos like five years from now
what even would the landscape of like
the internet and the online world and
tech
even look like envisioning content
creation as a career
felt like i was looking into this like
deep dark
murky pit so dark that i couldn't even
see the bottom of it
and all of that unknown about my life
and the future
directly fed straight into my anxiety
about everything
full disclosure i've had anxiety for
years now and all these
life changes kind of just made it more
intense for years my instinct when i had
anxiety was to just like
brace against it and fight it and that
was the natural reaction to
all of this ambiguity but this is when i
learned one of the most
valuable lessons about my anxiety my
therapist taught me that
if i fight my anxiety it'll only come
back bigger
that concept was so difficult for me to
grasp at first
it's just so counter-intuitive why
wouldn't you fight it like i didn't want
to have anxiety
obviously so what you're supposed to
just like let it flow through you
and take over and do whatever it wants
so the natural
instinct is to fight it and i would
resist it with
all of my might i would thrash against
it
but every time the same thing would
happen it would just get worse
my therapist compared it to standing on
the beach as waves come at you
and trying to fight them as they crash
around you
these waves are made up of your
obstacles and anxieties
coming from all different places like
work or
family or your emotions and if you try
to stand still
and resist them and especially if you
try to fight
or think your way out of them you're
eventually gonna get
worn down and knocked over and thrown
around
like when i'm fighting against my own
brain and trying to make sense of
conflicting signals and intrusive
thoughts and nervousness and all of
these things
a bunch of new notion documents or to-do
lists or
strategic planning sessions aren't going
to do the trick
in keeping me grounded and at peace i
understand now that it's just much
easier
to stop resisting and to ride with your
anxiety
and the waves it makes and just go with
the flow ever since i tried this
approach
things have been better it's all helped
me kind of untangle the problem
and in a lot of ways let go i realized
that
i may not be able to make my anxiety go
away completely
or make bad things not happen but i can
learn to live with them
i think i just had to let go of the
instinct to hold on tightly to my plans
and goals
and control things so rigidly i feel
like you actually
limit yourself and your experiences when
you're holding on
so desperately it was like i was
squeezing my eyes shut the whole time
i had to open them to realize i wasn't
even allowing myself to live my life
my life has possibilities that i hadn't
even dreamed existed
and i couldn't even see them so now
instead of walking around blind
i try to see the world for what it is
and not
torture myself for worrying about
everything this whole process has made
me feel more
okay with ambiguity maybe that thing
will happen
maybe it won't i'll be riding the wave
either way
a year ago my goals were in one way or
the other
defined by others now i'm on my own
my goals and dreams are my own and
designed by me
my successes and failures are my own now
i understand what i want for my own life
and my new outlook has helped me to
realize that
sometimes it's just as simple as getting
good
sleep having a comfy place to call home
spending time with family good food
and laughter honestly i would say now
that i'm probably the most me i've been
in a
very long time i feel super fortunate
that i get to do exactly what i want to
do
in a city that i love and put energy
into the things and people i love most
and make a living doing it i've just
realized that life is like a big
choose your own adventure book with a
million different blank pads for you to
choose
and one of the best and most fun parts
of those books
is the surrender to the process you
don't totally know the consequences of
each choice
but you know that some of them will be
compelling and will take you somewhere
fulfilling
and also you can always look up in the
middle of the book and be like
i don't like where this adventure is
going today maybe i don't want to go on
a jungle adventure
i just prefer the idea of setting sail
on an adventure
where i don't know what might happen
rather than setting sail for like
a normal island kind of nearby that
everybody tells me is really nice
and they gave me the map already and
stuff it's called charting your own
course for a reason
you know and part of what that means is
that i literally have to chart my own
path
where it didn't exist before my position
as a youtuber
and the niche that i'm feeling literally
didn't exist before me
i don't have a roadmap and it is
hard a lot of the time
like i'm a 100 self-taught content
creator
i didn't even know how to work a camera
a couple years ago but i know now
that there's just so much that i haven't
experienced out in this ocean
i realized during my short time making
videos that there's just literally
so much that i had no idea even existed
but even that feels exciting like i'd
rather be open to the possibilities than
to turn them away
and i know that even though it's gonna
be a fun adventure
that doesn't mean that it's gonna be
easy it's probably gonna be more
difficult
but any struggle will still be
underlined with the fact that this is
all my journey a lot of it is just about
honoring my own feelings
which a lot of the time means facing
fear
finding a way to move on then reflecting
on what i've learned
at least that's the process i've managed
to work out so far
so instead of getting stuck on what
scares me i'm working to
adjust my perspective to focus on the
possibilities that this position affords
me
and letting things flow from that
positivity that feels more
productive than letting the difficulties
hit me head-on
and dwelling on them it feels like
everything has changed for me ever since
i changed my perspective to think in
this way
the world looks different and feels less
intense so
i don't know where i'm headed or frankly
what i'm even doing
a lot of the time but for the first time
in my life
i'm okay with that i'm here in the dark
deep end of the ocean
without a map and i feel good i know
it's where i should be
even though i still don't know what i'm
[Music]
doing
you